the special counsel who will be
appearing before this committee next
week found in his report that the
Russian government attacked the 2016 US
presidential election in quote sweeping
and systematic fashion unquote the
report also detailed ten instances of
possible obstruction of the
investigation of that most serious
matter as well as other possible
misconduct the Committee on the
judiciary has a constitutional
obligation to investigate credible
allegations of misconduct we have been
doing that through pursuing the
unredacted Muller report and key related
witnesses and documents there is no
substitute however for primary evidence
as the committee makes its decisions
which is why we have sought documents
and testimony from former White House
Counsel Donald began former White House
communications director hope Hicks and
former deputy White House Counsel Annie
Donaldson today we focus on 12
additional witnesses these include
government officials who work who worked
or continued to work in close proximity
to the President these witnesses also
include those outside of government who
have critical information in connection
with our investigation we will not rest
until we obtain their testimony and
documents so that this committee and
Congress can do the work that the
Constitution and the American people
expect of us